I'm Laurie Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks for
joining us
crocodile tears it's so sad that's the
focus of tonight's angle
Republicans removed congresswoman ilam
or Omar from the Foreign Affairs
committee another example of House
Republicans putting the show ahead of
any kind of policy agenda a blatant
get here and what is the difference
between rep Omar and these members could
it be the way that gentlemen this time
it's a political stunt and it is a
disservice to the American people what a
hideous miscarriage of Justice a
majority power exercising influence over
house committee assignments wow
and right on cue Squad members tried to
out outrage one another with their full
outrage
[Applause]
[Music]
wow A striking vocal similarity
the white supremacy happening is
unbelievable this is just a bunch of
racist gas lighting we all know it they
turn Congress into a place of
fear-mongering hate
this time has expired that our country
is failing you today through this
chamber the gentleman is no longer my
voice will get louder and stronger and
my leadership will be celebrated around
the world as it has been
foreign
ly disingenuous and yet so predictable
the party that presided over the
weaponization of government agencies
from the FBI to the EPA is suddenly
crying foul then why
because their committee position was
actually put to a vote how dare they be
held accountable for their own toxic
words in abysmal record
all naturally they're dog-eared scripts
about racism and misogyny came in handy
one of the disgusting legacies after 9
11 has been the targeting and racism
against Muslim Americans throughout the
United States of America and this is an
extension of that Legacy consistency
there is nothing consistent with the
Republican party's continued attack
except for the racism and incitement of
violence against women of color in this
body don't tell me this is about
consistency don't tell me that this is
about an abdic a condemnation of
anti-semitic remarks this is about
targeting women of color
now talk about a double standard when
Republicans lose committee assignments
it's tough luck when Democrats lose them
and are put up to an actual vote no less
it's Armageddon
but let's be blunt here
Omar lost her position on the Foreign
Affairs committee not because she's a
Muslim or wears a head scarf she lost it
because over the years she's made a
series of anti-Semitic comments
she wasn't treated unfairly the newly
elected house decided that they didn't
want someone with her views involved in
the oversight of U.S foreign policy
is free to serve on other committees but
she should not serve in this particular
role given her radical and anti-semitic
history
yeah I know she's made some apologies
but apparently they weren't convincing
I certainly did not or was not aware
that the word hypnotized was a Trope I
wasn't aware
of of the fact that there are tropes
about Jews and money
that has been a very enlightening uh
part of of this journey
oh this journey if Democrats want to
make this an issue well they could try
but the notion that she was
discriminated against because of her
race or her religious background is
laughable
we don't need to run through her old
clips we're all sick of hearing her and
hearing them
the notion that the party of Adam Schiff
and Nancy Pelosi have any leg to stand
on to complain about any of this is
absurd
they packed the Jan 6 committee with
Toadies and true two trump-hating
Republicans and they kick Marjorie
Taylor Greene off all committees because
they didn't like reviews
at the time we warned Democrats they
were setting a precedent that would come
back to bite them they didn't listen
the GOP though was not doing this in a
tit-for-tat moment kicking Schiff and
swallow small well off their Intel
committee or Omar offer foreign affairs
committee now Republicans by doing that
were being pragmatic
you know swalwell should not serve on
the Intel I'd love to take a show of
hands here how many believe if you're a
member of Congress and the FBI says
nothing but the moment your leadership
appoints you to the Intel committee the
FBI comes knocking on the leadership
store and says we have a problem this
person has a relationship with a Chinese
spy how many believe that that person
should stay on Intel now the chairman of
the Intel committee
Adam Schiff I actually believe I helped
him because what he did to the Intel
committee he used that position as
chairman knowing classified information
that others didn't and he conveyed to
the American public something that was
not true to try to confuse him on a
number of times
bingo I gotta tell you McCarthy has
definitely handled this so far well the
press of course came at him teeth bared
today he hit back
tit for cat retribution that your new
majority is taking against a democratic
member of the house is this the message
you want to send to voters no and that's
the clear part how it's not Tit for Tat
so Democrats in the last Congress
removed Republican members from all
committees
they even judged one Republican member
not based upon what she had said as a
member of Congress but what she said
prior to ever getting here this is
nothing like the last Congress where you
never had an open rule so I've had
Democrats coming up to me telling me
we're running it much better especially
the time allotment
now lost in all the recent praise for
Nancy Pelosi as a historic brilliant
speaker is the following
she made a huge mistake by giving these
Fringe fools those assignments on
committees in the first place
Omar never should have been on the you
know the uh her committee but Pelosi
moved to placate the squad on that and
so many other issues like putting metal
detectors in Congress the fences around
the capitol radical climate policies and
in the end that hard turn to the left
was a major reason why they lost the
majority
so the Democrats find themselves in an
unenviable position not because of
systemic racism or political Revenge
they're in this mess because they abuse
their position
they acted irresponsibly and vengefully
and they lied over and over again
including about January 6.
two nights ago we heard this from NBC
News
the January 6 committee's final report
was more than 800 pages but some
material did not make the cut including
much of its findings on the failures of
federal law enforcement leading up to
the attack the chief investigator of the
January 6 committee says the government
could have prevented it law enforcement
had a very direct role in contributing
to certainly the failures the security
failures that led to the violence
uh the law enforcement had a direct role
security failures that led to the
violence excuse me
I love how kind of NBC acts like okay
this is a one day story nothing more to
talk about
Pelosi and Schumer could have stopped
January 6 before it started they ignored
all the warnings why
we're going to get that question
answered
now if a real Republican was actually on
that January 6 committee we would have
heard about this months ago
but that's how the Democrats ran the
house zero transparency aided by a media
that not only refused to hold them
accountable but actively ran cover for
them
well those days are over
so buckle up Libs and dry those
crocodile tears Republicans have two
years worth of questions that need
answering
this is our house now
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else